black migrants in Tunisia are facing a
massive spike in hate crime and
thousands of them want to leave the
country for Europe here's what you need
to know
[Music]
when we go to the government hospitals
they will not attend to us because we
are blacks
tunisia's president describes
sub-Saharan migrants as a threat to
national identity and a source of
violence and crime in the country since
this statement racialized attacks have
become a more and more common
we have really have a lot of challenges
we have a lot of people maybe we could
visit them you see them those who were
attacked because the pronouncement by
the president of Tunisia has led their
to some kind of instigation there's an
aggression from the locals the youths
guess this child Kobe broke both of his
legs escaping a group of Tennessean
teenagers
where we jump down they used stick they
were frogging us we should go back to
our country you know that kind of thing
that speaking their Arab
yeah
the escalation and racial tension has
sparked Mass protests decrying the state
endorsed violence demonstrators are
calling for the government to put out a
strong message of support for foreign
immigrants and give clear instructions
to Security Forces to protect them
instead there's been a rise in arrests
Tunisia straddles the Mediterranean Sea
and migrants are making the dangerous
Crossing from there into Europe dozens
are drowning before they make it and
those that do are facing stringent
anti-migrant policies on arrival
and in tunisia's capital many are parked
outside of embassies for their
protection praying for relocation I
decided to say okay see this what they
are doing to us let's just leave
everything God will make you to deliver
safely but the question is where will
they go